[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
Взагалі, румуни тут...
Вже склалася така частка людей —
більша частина, як 60 відсотків.
Але принаймні ми живемо у розумінні й мирі
з угорцями, українцями,
росіянами, євреями, німцями.
Типове Закарпаття, що можу сказати!
Традиційні, автентичні мармороські будинки,
які побудовані колись румунами,
їхня архітектура складалася повністю із дерева.
У них був свій стиль, вони старалися поєднати,
щоби було all inclusive,
як кажуть — все в одному будинку.
Дуже зручно було зробити, як кажуть,
такий парадний дворик.
Там завжди, знаєте...
Зараз в деяких селах можна побачити
таку важливу деталь, як старі дідусі чи бабусі
виходять і сидять саме на лавці, біля віконечка —
саме у таких маленьких двориках.
У зв'язку з тим, що в нас дуже поєднана культура,
в нас уже люди більше мають таку тенденцію —
«у кого більше хижа», як кажуть у нас на Закарпатті.
Тому автентичність саме таких
будівель залишилась дуже мала.
[розмовляють румунською]
[розмовляють румунською, дзвонить телефон]
Так, добрий день!
Я передзвоню вам трішки пізніше,
бо я на іспиті зараз.
[румунською] Слухайте, купляємо для випускного вчителям те, що я вам показував?
[румунською] По тридцять гривень.
[румунською] Давайте візьмемо.
Знаєте такі штуки? Я вам показувала...
[румунською] Успіху вам!
[румунською] Я зачекаю, поки ви зайдете...
Хто йде вступати — треба здавати ЗНО.
Я, як класний керівник, прийшов з ними.
Обов'язковою тут є лише українська мова і література, а потім вони собі обирають.
У нас є угорська школа, румунська школа, румунський ліцей,
українська школа та школа-інтернат.
Незважаючи на те, що це — румунська школа,
діти чудово розмовляють українською мовою.
Зараз можете побачити, що скажуть вам
не «здравствуйте», а «добрий день».
І ще одна дуже цікава історія:
майже все життя в Солотвині
тут стояв монумент вєлікому вождю,
але, згідно з законами, у нас декомунізація
сталася ще у девʼяносто першому році,
тому тут стоїть Богдан-Зиновій Хмельницький.
В Румунії я вчився на магістра з історії.
І взагалі я вступив туди, щоб поділитися
досвідом Румунії з українськими учнями.
Моя румунська для Румунії — це суржик.
Але потрібно було відновлюватися, відучитися.
Коли я вступив туди вчитися,
багато хто дивися на мене як...
Багато людей на мене дивилися й так:
«Га, що ти сказав?»
Бррр...
[насвистує]
Гой-гой!
Бррр...
Я дуже любив овець змалку.
Сир робити дуже любив я.
Трумбіту, трумбітати так, як я трумбечу,
тут по Україні нема, немає так трумбече.
Я був у Румунії, та і там нема уже таких, шо...
Там є цімбори [друзі], але немає таких трумбетайл:
старі повмирали, а молоді не хочуть учитися вже.
♪ [грає на трембіті] ♪
[собака гавкає]
Дуже жарко!
[румунською] До того краю йде червона доріжка...
Там червоним буде написано «Випуск-2020».
— Стільці там поставиш?
— Ні, тільки тут, три-чотири рядки...
І там буде стрічка,
а за стрічкою будуть стояти люди.
У нас є приготовлена зона.
І звідти, зверху туди, буде інша доріжка, підвішена.
— Зверху? Якого кольору?
— Білого, але просвічується.
Супер!
Ми народилися тут, в Білій Церкві.
Зараз ми проживаємо тут.
Поки що переїжджати я не думаю.
Це румунське село з самого початку.
Румунія тут, через річку.
Десь за два кілометри.
Всі кажуть: йо, яке тут село, які...
Як шикарно, стільки грошей!
Тут дуже багато працюється насправді.
В селі не дуже модно вступати кудись.
Мало хто з випускників йде далі в університет
чи на якісь курси хоча би — то не модно.
Модно заробляти закордоном та будувати
великі хати, «замки» та купувати автомобілі.
[румунською] Слухайте, робимо звичайну репетицію. Спини випрямлені. З танцем, зі всім.
[румунською] Але я вам скажу, коли... Добре?
[румунською] Йдемо туди, звідти починаємо...
Евелін буде між вами.
[румунською] Вас... Раз, два, три, чотири, пять, шість, сім, вісім. Він буде після четвертого. Добре? Пішли.
Тут іде мова про молодих, більш про молодих...
Щоб вони лишалися вдома та мали можливість —
і школярі та й всі, багато хто...
Вони їдуть вступати.
Вони хочуть щось робити.
Вони вже розуміють, що можна і тут щось зробити.
Лишитися.
Відкрили танцювальну групу для них —
сучасні танці.
Спробуємо робити такі культурні румунські вечірки.
Маємо тут і музей румунський.
Там всі зустрічаємося по традиціям давнім,
як наші прадіди, бабусі.
Їм подобається дуже.
[насвистує]
[розмовляють румунською]
Кожне село має свої традиції...
Тобто ми маємо одну традицію,
в іншого села традиція вже інша.
Перший раз я вчив дружину доїти та сир чинити.
Та донька ще так, а так уже ніхто.
Є такі, шо кажуть: «Ой, я би не сидів тут»...
Так ти б не сидів, каже, а я від малого, коли чую звук, знаєш, мені волосся дибки стає.
Але я знаю від малого, його тягне.
Наприклад, є такі, що,
коли йде дощ, кажуть: «Я не буду».
А там були такі старі люди, та з ними я був.
Мені це подобалося змалечку,
та я вже майже 37 років з ними сиджу...
Потрібно зберігати традиції тому, що з часом люди,
на жаль, починають забувати.
Забувати коріння — це ну така собі справа.
Я — нацменшина, я — етнічний румун,
але громадянин України і поважаю це.
Тому я кажу, що я — український румун.
За що я люблю це місце?
По-перше, за поєднання традицій.
Якщо хоче людина побачити толерантність
в Україні, нехай приїжджає в Солотвино.
Це якраз така толерантність між і між.
Тут немає одної національності,
тут нема одної релігії.
Тут якраз все є в такому балансі.
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку USAID]